15 à 30 minutes c'est le temps consacré
au repas par un jeûne sur deux pas le
temps peu d'argent bref toutes les
conditions qui poussent à échouer sur
une terrasse de restaurant très en vogue
sont réunis si on manger tous les jours
ça ça serait absolument impouventable
mais là cont vous goûter les jeunes ont
un faible pour les aliments plutôt gras
à l'heure du déjeuner la majorité des
1625 ans est attiré par des sandwichs
hamburgers ou pizz le tout bien sûr
arrosé de soda trop sucré en clair un
jeûe sur trois ne connaît pas la
composition d'un repas équilibré du
poisson de la viande des légumes des
frites que moi quand c'est pas ma mère
qui fait qui fait à
manger je mange un peu des des
cochonneries é clair quoi les
adolescents quittent de plus en plusôt
la table familiale pour fréquenter dans
le meilleur des cas cantines ou
restaurants universitaires les
nutritionnistes tirent la sonnett
d'alarme car les mauvaises habitudes
d'aujourd'hui auront demain des
conséquences sur la santé des jeunes